♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE GREAT THING ABOUT
A GOOD ECONOMY: EVERYONE GETS A
PIECE OF THE PIE.
HOSTESSES GIVING WORKERS
WORTH OF FREE FOOD.
ONE MULTIPACK OF THEIR FAVORITE
ITEM A WEEK.
I WOULD EAT THAT IN AN HOUR.
WHY LOOK A GIFT HORSE IN THE
THESE FREE SNACKS, THEY REALLY
ARE PERFECT SIMPLE.
NO ONE IS GETTING FREE KALE
UNDER TRUMP.
BUT HERE IS YOUR HO-HO.
THIS IS HOSTESS, WHO FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND EVEN SHUT DOWN UNDER THAT
PRESIDENT.
NOW THE TAX CHANGE GIVES THE
COMPANY THAT CHANCE TO INCREASE
COMPENSATION, SHARING THE
COMPANY'S SUCCESS WITH ITS
MAKES YOU FAT.
I KNOW THE RESPONSE WE ARE GOING
TO GET FROM THE PELOSI BOT.
THERE WILL BE CRUMBS FROM ALL
THE FREE FOOD GIVEN FROM A
COMPANY THAT FOUND NEW LIFE IN A
CLIMATE THAT MAKES IT POSSIBLE.
IT'S A BIGGER STORY, ONE OF PURE
I THINK WE BETTER DO THAT TOO.
IF PELOSI OR DEBBIE WASSERMAN
SCHULTZ CAN SEE THE GOODNESS AND
THAT, THEN THERE IS THE REAL
DING-DONG.
FINISHING ON A PUN, DANA.
>> Dana: YOU ARE GOING TO OUT
THEM OUT RIGHT NOW.
>> Greg: THIS CORPORATE TAX
WHAT'S INTERESTING, THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS WATCHING A REAL-LIFE
ECONOMIC 101 LESSON.
IT'S A SUPPLY AND DEMAND THING.
I WOULD ASK THEM IF I COULD GET
AN EXTRA $5 A WEEK INSTEAD OF
THE CALORIES.
>> Greg: I OPEN THIS UP AND I
HAVE TO ASK HIM WHY DOES IT HAVE
TWINKIES FOR A WHILE?
THAT WAS AMAZING.
BRING THAT BACK.
>> Dana: THEY HAVE THE OTHER
ONES.
THEY HAD ZINGERS.
>> Greg: JUAN, THIS IS GOOD
NEWS.
SPREAD LIKE TRUMP SAYING THIS IS
THE BIGGEST TAX CUT UPPER AND OF
COURSE THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Dana: IF THIS HAD HAPPENED
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA, LIKE IF
YOU DONE THE TAX CUT LIKE HE
WONDER WHAT THE RIGHT WOULD BE
SAYING.
THEY WOULD BE SAYING IT'S NOT
ENOUGH.
>> Juan: IS NOT ENOUGH.
OKAY.
CHECK MY THOUGHT IS, WILL MAKE F
CHECK MY THOUGHT IS, WILL MAKE R
WALL STREET IS SAYING THIS IS
FOR THE COMPANIES, INCREASED
DIVIDENDS FOR SHAREHOLDERS, OR
INCREASE EXECUTIVE PAY.
LOT OF AMERICA.
>> Juan: IF YOU THINK IS
BENEFICIAL TO THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY, IT'S BENEFICIAL TO
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HAVE MONEY.
>> Jesse: OKAY, EVERYBODY HAS
A LITTLE MONEY AND IT IS
BENEFICIAL TO EVERYBODY BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO AP, THIS IS HOT OFF
THE PRESS.
TAX BILL BEGINNING TO DELIVER
BIGGER PAYCHECKS TO WORKERS.
TAX CUT.
THAT'S A LOT OF AMERICANS.
AVERAGE MIDDLE CLASS FAMILY
GETTING $1,000 IN TAX RELIEF
THIS YEAR.
UPS JUST ANNOUNCED $13,000 PER
WORKER GOING INTO THEIR
PENSIONS.
LOWE'S IS OFFERING $1,000
BONUSES.
THIS IS BIG MONEY, REAL MONEY.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE FINALLY COME
AROUND.
BECAUSE I CARE ABOUT YOU SO
MUCH, I DON'T WANT YOU WALKING
IN TIMES SQUARE BECAUSE OF THOSE
GUYS ARE PLAYING THREE CARD
MONTE, YOU WOULD FALL FOR IT.
>> Jesse: I HAVE, AND I WILL
ADMIT IT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE HOSTESS
WITH THE MOST -- MOSTEST.
>> Kimberly: IT IS SWEET.
WHY NOT CELEBRATE THE SUCCESSES
AND THAT TAX REFORM IS RESULTING
IN MORE DOLLARS IN PEOPLE'S
PURCHASING POWER, CONSUMERISM.
I LIKE THE COMPANIES ARE
TREATING THEIR PLAYS WELL.
OF THEM HOME.
>> Greg: OF OTHER COMPANIES
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GIVE WHAT
YOU WORK ON, YOU CAN TAKE IT
HOME.
LIKE WE WOULD GET FREE NEWS.
FOX GIVES US A BIG PILE OF
NEWSPAPERS TO TAKE HOME.
>> Juan: THEY SHOULD GIVE US
REAL NEWS.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Juan: WALMART SAYS THEY ARE